you shot a meter you're not even gonna
believe this and I'm almost kind of like
I'm gonna find embarrassed to say it I
guess I'm just like insecure about it I
I was in a music video you know like a
music video you see on the internet and
they used to have it on MTV but now it's
just on um it's on YouTube and this
music is by bad baby and you know our
beehad baby I think be hard baby is uh
she is that you know catch me outside
you know I'm saying catch me outside you
know it's like before venmo they had
cashed me outside and and she was on dr.
Phil you know it's like dr. Phil's
stepdaughter or something and she got
angry at dr. Phil and they were fighting
and um and she was impersonating you
know kind of more of an urban girl type
of vibe anyhow I got to work with bad
baby and she's got a rap album out now
and she has a there's a video coming out
she has a song called trust me so let me
tell you what happened for me so a
friend of mine is the director of the
video and he just did her last video and
it's called Gucci flip flops and we'll
put the links to them below you can
check it out and mine is the one I'm in
though when I'm in isn't out yet and so
I get a I get a text from the director
and he's like hey would you be
interested in doing this here's the link
of the last one I sent so watch the last
one I'm like wow you know this thing has
you know it's got fifty something
million views it's it's cool-looking
it's really artistic it's funny it's fun
I'm like yeah I'll do that you know I'll
definitely I'll definitely try this
thing out so oh oh but first I read the
script right and in the script I play a
pervert I play a pervert man and if you
don't know what a perverted as a pervert
is say you're a masturbator so you like
to masturbate right but say you don't
but say you now suddenly you take your
show on the road
that's a pervert because a masturbator
is somebody masturbates at their house
you know a lot of you know could be a
man or a woman some men like to spray
out and ladies like to kind of more
spray in and and a master a master
baiter is somebody that does that you
know sprays out or in but a pervert as
somebody that's like ah but you do that
indoors that's somebody who sprays out
or in but also indoors they do it inside
of a domicile in an igloo under a hat
you know some people if they're you know
if you're track if you're stuck outdoors
and you want to jerk off some people
back in the day they would dig a hole
and get down in just get under all the
dirt put all the dirt back on top of
them and then jerk off down in the dirt
you know and that's old school that's
[ __ ] that's some 1900 [ __ ] you know
that's 1900s style but this uh but a
perverted somebody that instead of doing
it behind closed doors they go out and
do it out in the bout or they do it at a
party or they do it at a you know Kenson
era you know somebody blows out the
candles on there in the distance
you know warming up one more freakin one
more candy there in the distance you
know starting up a little cake of their
own you know and that's a pervert and so
anyway the thing on there it's like you
have to play a pervert and I'm like and
look I'm not a pervert man I'm not a
pedophile I've never done anything like
that and I've babysat overnight I've
babysat overnight with my nieces and
nephews countless times and I feel
eternally grateful and thankful that I I
don't have that that infection that
disease because that's that that's a
that's a troubling disease you know and
we look at those people that have those
types of things and we say man you know
it's it's so unfortunate for their
victims and it is but it's also nobody's
starting their life out choosing to be
that way you know I'm saying choosing to
wear a backpack made out of Satan you
know choosing to run around with the
dark arts just flowing so strong
inside of their veins that they you know
they almost would cut their risk just to
relieve themselves of the dark desires
that they have and and so anyway I got
that dude next thing you know I'm
reading the script I'm like damn there's
a creepy guy in here and then I get to
the end I'm like oh there's only really
two people in it but Baja baby and and
the creepy guy I'm like [ __ ] dude I'm
the creepy guy I'm the pervert so next
thing you know the director text me is
like well look man uh David Spade
recommended you and I'm like oh wow
that's that's crazy because first of all
David Spade is one of my favorite um
entertainers of all time I mean you know
the fact I mean we have Chris Farley his
uh a painting of Chris Farley up here in
our studio and the fact that he got to
work with him black sheep Tommy Boy
you know what's the the movie uh I think
he was incentive a woman I think or
something I don't know but or he just
gets a lot of us a you know but um but I
love David Spade Oh Joe Dirt and people
you know and I thought Joe Dirt a lot of
you don't know this I thought it was a
documentary when I first saw it and I
remember when I finally got to interview
David Spade he came on allegedly which
uh was a podcast that I've done with
Matthew Cole Weis for a while and he
came on to allegedly and he's like and
and I was like hey did a lot of orphans
like reach out to you and Joe Dirt came
out and he's like what are you talking
about and I was like whoa and I
explained to him you know and he's like
dude that's not a [ __ ] documentary
he's like you're an idiot and I was like
oh that's awesome and you know David
Spade has called me an idiot and made me
feel good but anyhow so next thing you
know the directors like why don't you
get in touch with David Spade and I'm
like I don't know David Spade's number
you know what I'm saying
you know I'm not just walking around
with people like David Spade's number or
people like you know who else Kris
Kringle freaking Rain Man any
yells dude Wolverine who the [ __ ] does
this guy think I am you know Katy Perry
I don't have just ultimate numbers in my
phone so he sends me david spade's
number and like oh wow what do I do with
david spade's number so I'm like just
like I'm like I don't really call day
and I know David Spade through we have a
mutual friend Adam egit who booked his
the Booker at The Comedy Store and I
know him through just seeing him in
circles and we chat sometimes a little
bit and he's I would consider his
buddies but I wouldn't say that we're
really friends yet you know because we
just haven't know him well enough and
you know it's that weird thing were like
I don't want to like I don't feel like a
fanboy at around him or anything but I
am a fan of his work so it's you know
it's it's not a it's not uncomfortable
but it's it's um you know there's an
admiration there that sometimes I get
excited about maybe I can't hide and he
might be like Lana there's a fun
conversation but your cheeks are all
flushed or your eyes are flickering
while we're talking you know or your
erect like what's going on buddy so you
know sometime I can't hide my you know
just genuine excitement that God just
sends out just vibing out through my
through my you know my eyelids or
through my even my crotch sometimes if
I'm you know keyed up or excited so next
thing you know I have David Spade's
number and I call it goes to voicemail
and then I get a call back and this is
um and so I'm like well what the hell
how do I do I stand up do I sit down and
I'm saying to a lay down how do I answer
the phone when David Spade calls so um
you know I'm just trying to like I go
outside I was inside of a loud place and
I'm like I don't want him to think that
I you know hang out in loud places you
know I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
thinking dude and then I was like oh
dude I don't feel like I'm very tall
because I always have this thing in my
head like I don't feel like um because I
am 6 feet tall even though some people
will say I'm not and if you look at like
old you know older if use like an old
[ __ ] ruler from a long time ago where
they didn't really put that full inch in
there then yeah then I definitely make
it but if you use kind of
newer rulers where things are a lot more
can you know certain I kind of get there
and I think I get there and some people
say I don't but I think I come in right
at six feet you know and strong that
looking you know I'm so if you know I'm
right there five eleven in seven eight
stood and if the wind blows up or they
don't [ __ ] kind of pick me up just
enough to get me at that six foot but I
always have these insecurities you know
how the insecurities of having that you
know I have a limited neck my neck
doesn't go very far even we've talked
about that on here and I talk about it a
lot you know I'm saying I can't really
look around that much so after you to
look forward or I have to turn around
and then also look forward which is
behind me at that point cuz I turned
around and so next thing you know man
I so I stand on a bench there's a bench
right there so I'm like well [ __ ] I want
to sound tall when I talked to David
Spade on the phone even though our II
know he already knows how I am right so
next II know I'm on the phone and he's
like he starts telling me about the
video and I said well look I just you
know I'm a little nervous I don't wanna
be seen as like a pervert you know I
don't want to be seen as a a PDF file
and so he's like nah man he's like this
is a chance for you to like act you know
like you you get to be funny a lot but
you get to be you know creepy and dark
and I'm like well you know I have a um I
said I've struggled over my life with
you know masturbation and stuff like
that and he's like what the [ __ ] you
talking about I was like I don't know
and so then we kind of thankfully got
out of that topic for a second but I was
trying to tell him that I've been into
some dark arts Ernie you know you know
I've had some issues and addiction
issues and stuff but um he's just like
look this is a chance for you to play a
creeper you can be a creeper and that's
it so next thing you know I text the
director and I said I'm in and two days
later I'm on I'm on set with bad bad
baby I mean look this [ __ ] up I thought
it was be hot baby and then I thought I
was like well her fan base has to be
called be Haj jihad right but it is it
is the
it bad when I first thought it's like a
sheep owner yeah Danielle Brooke goalie
that be had baby you know catch me
outside
so anyway next you know I'm one set and
boom there I am and I'm on it's like and
dude it to a real music video there's
like smoke and there are there's like a
table in the distance with everybody
eating orange slices and like fancy
oranges like oranges from [ __ ] Sweden
or Portland and everybody's you know
they have all kind of cashews and uh and
they have uh you know people they have
some dudes walking on with radios and
[ __ ] weren't doing [ __ ] but just you
know carrying around electronics
basically and it was in in the next you
know I'm in this dude I'm playing I'm
playing a pervert and I'm playing a
pervert and and we did we did the whole
video and and we did a night shoot and
it was in it was wild and then I came
back two days later and we did some
pick-me-ups so it's just gonna be
something you're gonna be able to it was
the craziest thing like you would never
think I would be in that and and then
there I was man but the crazy party is
here's one of the weirdest things so you
know a couple of my friends knew about
it and I don't even know if I'm supposed
to tell anybody about it but you know
what I'm saying this is this is what we
do on here we just say what what's going
on and so and my buddies are texting me
and they're like hey man that chick is
so hot bro set me up
and what dude what are you talking I'm
playing a pervert bruh because of God
like you because of guys like you I'm
here and this is the role of men so it
was just intense man our buddies like
set me up with her my total must set you
up with a child but there's a lot that's
called sex trafficking
that's called sex trafficking man so
it's just you know it's just wild but
then also you know she gets its while
how we sexualized I don't want to say
that we sexualized children but there's
the industry like you know you'll put a
young girl and have her
look sexual you know if they're
developed you'll have them look sexual
and I just start to wonder like I guess
there's if somebody's a you know is
really a pervert then they're just they
can't they don't know when to say okay
that's a that is a child or that's a kid
or that's legally not okay and then you
know and then it is okay you know
because that starting line is 18 so
that's the starting line but uh but yeah
I guess that's the difference if some
people can't shut down that part of
their brain where they want to you know
join uh you know they want to you know
coach children's softball or whatever or
that kind of stuff anyway I don't know
why I got in all that but you can see me
in a bad baby music video coming out and
look I was so nervous like there's one
part where I'm like because she catches
me and I'm like pinned down on this like
Dexter style deal on my [ __ ] you know
and uh and I'm Mike and I even said to
the director I was like dude I just want
to like I'm okay with I said just tell
me this tell me if I look like somebody
who can't act trying to act that's what
I do not want to look like that he's
like nah man you did a good job and it
was but it was pretty crazy man it was
just crazy it was crazy to be in there
and uh and people are like well what's
Danielle bergoglio like what's behind
baby like and I said well she's the cash
me outside girl you know she all she
know and that's who she is and she's
also a kid she's nice she's uh she's a
ninth grader so when you talk to her
it's like talking to somebody in the
ninth grade you know but she definitely
a lot of swagger she was definitely fun
she was fun to be around she had a good
sense of humor I thought like the second
time we did pickup shots which was last
night or two nights ago she made it like
it was it was easy to joke around and
stuff with her I mean if anything what I
realized about myself was that
definitely because I look I haven't been
around a fifteen-year I don't hang out
around any people this age and so good
hey first of all you know
and it was just you know I realized like
oh yeah these these kids this is another
generation they live in a world that I
do not know about and I am thankful that
I don't know about it and I'm thankful
that I'm just here playing a pervert or
PDF file today just as an actor and not
suffering with that in my real life and
I'm grateful for that man thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz this
is alarming